un caso que destapó un sentimiento de
inseguridad generalizado entre las
mujeres en reino unido el oficial de
policía wayne q sense fue condenado a
cadena perpetua por haber secuestrado
violado y asesinado a sara ever art en
marzo de este año la investigación
determinó que excusiones aprovechó su
posición como oficial para detener a la
víctima e introducirla en un automóvil
alquilado el juez del caso determinó que
sus actos fueron premeditados
el secuestro la violación y el asesinato
de sara fue uno de los eventos más
espantosos de los 190 años de historia
del servicio de la policía metropolitana
esta audiencia ha revelado la brutalidad
total de los crímenes de este hombre con
trazas mans
de veras desapareció mientras caminaba a
su casa tras encontrarse con unos amigos
fue encontrada muerta estrangulada siete
días después de su desaparición en el
bosque a pocos metros de un terreno
propiedad de cozens en un comunicado la
familia expresó sosiego por la condena
nada puede mejorar las cosas nada puede
traer de vuelta a sara pero saber que
estará encarcelado para siempre trae
algo de alivio
wayne q sense ocupó un puesto de
confianza como oficial de policía y
estamos indignados y asqueados de que
haya abusado de esa confianza para
llevar a sara a la muerte la noticia
destapó el miedo que muchas mujeres
sienten al caminar solas en horas
nocturnas por las calles del país y en
otras situaciones en las que sienten que
pueden ser agredidas el caso despertó
una ola de protestas contra las
agresiones de género y en exigencia de
que las autoridades actúen para
garantizar la seguridad de las mujeres